it's time for screen junkies movie bytes
ah
what in the world you guys it's movie
fights we're here or doing it hashtag
movie fights live and I got to say hi to
Al nation Percival's in the house
we are kicking off down we're kicking
off on June movie fights we got the Dan
Merle Invitational the oh I almost got
him I should have had him tournament uh
and it's all culminating on a big July
fourth not just America's birthday but
it's going to be the last fighter
standing which you know just as big in
context and so today we got spoiler
alert yeah I just said then we roll
invitation Dan rolls at the table yes it
is the all fact checkers edition so when
many people have sat in that chair and
when Dan is not taking us to the facts
oh and we have some of the finest minds
that have graced that share with us
right now today
first up oh you know this fella he wears
the the mortarboard in the gown because
he he drinks and he knows things that's
game of thrones TV fights won Harris the
professor it's going on it's been a
while since I've movie fought I'm gonna
shake the cobwebs off mm-hmm yeah um
well we just had to check with the
doctors and everything because you
received a like a concussion and a TKO
standing eight-count you're laughing no
I'm just you why need you've won your
last I think I did yeah no you you've
got some damage I was like
no I was just just talking crap as per
usual yeah Mon great to have you here in
this seat but you've got some formidable
foes oh um she's making some snow
standing eight-count her she's been
making noise um I will remind you she
has the only clean sweep in movie fights
history it's not true a 400 shutout has
ever been a 400 shutout I think I think
perhaps Greg Alba is also done oh very
rare okay maybe one of two in history
and she's the voice of the people
Daniel Radford I thank you and um
actually I have to fact-check I have
never sat in the fact-check seat before
I've always been the voice to people so
I wanted to fact-check that right now so
that I officially count as a fact
checker and this man needs no
introduction but we'll give him one
anyway he is the reigning the levites
champion you know him from all over
screen junkies and like when it comes to
just like movie contests and trivia
things he's pretty good at him he also
meant just destroys it in the Schmo down
dan the man Merle doesn't know I like
did you in love looks like the set of
Game of Thrones around here dude long go
to Starbucks together
slowly on the table next time naturally
I bribed the judge here we do look like
Denarius with our cup of coffee
dan good luck to all of you and a very
special treat weighing in on the
questions and the facts along with
myself Wow it is the original
fact-checkers from TV fights look at can
nap sock and Billy piss together again
to great taste everybody happy to be
here
hi Roxy hey Ken it's like in Carta and
Wikipedia together on the askjeeves
did you do anything special to get ready
for this fact change to crack your
knuckles did you do some stretching say
what I did how I stole some candy from
the screen junkies break room yeah what
what what a sweet crime that Billy biz
no are the voice of the people what's
going on brother you want to tell us how
that works
I'd love to how you can vote in the
polls be there during the fights
we encourage you to use those but the
only poll that counts for this match is
the poll that happens on YouTube and so
the way that will work is that in case
of a tie or in case no one can figure
anything out we will turn to you and
then your vote will count towards the
eventual winner do you want me to do
dankmemes
what do we need I would love dankmemes
I'd also love refinancing mortgage tips
if you could help please send it along
all right congrats to home owner Billy
business thank you for the assist you
know what let's let's do some movie
fighting jte drop that sick ass package
[Music]
all right Thank You Thor JT best package
in the biz
so in honor of x-men Dark Phoenix let's
honor that 120 percent on Rotten do
anything but because there's an x-men
movie coming out there it is we asked
who gives the best performance in any
single x-men movie in any X movie Wow
there it is there it is man a lot of
good performances across those films and
let's start with player number one one
that's me so I went a little outside the
box I know that the temptation with a
question like this is to think about the
people who've been in a bunch of these
movies you know sorry we've gotta know
their characters over a bunch of time
but I was thinking who gives a great
one-off performance and I really think
the best maybe ever in any of these
movies Brian Cox as William Stryker in
x2 x-men United he only has one movie to
come in and sort of create this whole
character for us and he does such a
compelling job that William Stryker
actually became a major character and
throughout this whole French as he's
played by three actors in different
expert movies and I think almost all of
that is because Cox is so memorable in
this movie he's the guy who created
Wolverine he's the guy that created
Magneto's prison he's sort of this
driving force behind anti-mutant ISM
throughout the entire franchise it's a
very compelling Pro incidence it's
complicated its layered - we find out in
that movie that Stryker hates mutants
because his own son Jason is a powerful
mutant who wasn't in control of his
powers who couldn't be helped by
Professor Xavier and who ended up
killing his own mother and that's driven
strikers hatred of mutants were sort of
drives everything else he does that's a
really interesting backstory I think the
fact that he isn't though he's
incredibly sort of evil in the movie
he's doing all of these really devious
things and you know we sort of blame him
for Wolverines trauma and the same way
he's giving us this sort of compelling
three-dimensional believable guy I mean
Brian Cox no matter how silly the
material is he sort of dives and Ian
always gives it is sort of a hundred
percent and it's a
really good performance so I'm going
with Brian Cox's William Stryker okay
lawn strikes first with William Stryker
Brian Cox Danielle um so I'm going with
I was gonna do that thing where you like
set it up and I'm not doing that so I'm
going with Michael Fassbender from Days
of Future past he other than obviously
playing young hot magneto
he also and performances sometimes we
boiled them down to speeches and I know
that he gives several very good ones in
this movie he has that fantastic speech
on the plane where he's accusing Charles
of saying that you know the abandoned
all of them he has that great speech
about humanity fearing that which is
different when he is doing his big last
stand at the end of the movie but it's
not just these speeches and I am trying
to cuz you're right we're talking about
specific movies so I'm not going to be
drawing from anything else but in this
movie specifically I feel like he has
several great moments where magneto
really gets to shine and Michael
Fassbender gets to show that he is a
good actor and he is more than hot
magneto although he is also hot magneto
alright Danielle coming in hot with
young hot magneto Dan my choice is from
the film Logan but it is not Hugh
Jackman sorry sorry because this is
actually my favorite performance in the
movie and it is Patrick Stewart Patrick
Stewart as Professor Xavier and Logan I
think is easily the best performance and
any mu any x-men branded movie you can
give me another performance as if we
were about to do and I will I will
defend this one and it's and it's mainly
because first of all it gives us a shade
of that character that we see in no
other place in any other film and
anywhere else in this franchise it
allows Patrick Stewart to explore parts
of Charles Xavier that he has not been
able to and other films and really it
drives home you so much of the story is
about Wolverine and his character but
really Charles is given a lot of the way
that the world
the weight of the world is on his
shoulders and it's it's the death of a
dream really for so much is here's
here's this person who prided him who
prides himself his power was his mind
and what is the worst thing you can
imagine
for someone who's literal superpower is
their mind it's losing it it's losing
that mind and not only are you losing it
you're hurting other people in the
process it is such a tragic performance
but also it it has this this sliver of
hope and that's really what that that
movie is driven by is and the whole
story of Logan has kicked off by the
fact that Xavier finds in this mutant
who's not supposed to exist this spark
of this dream that he had
and it really propels the movie forward
into what happens so much more to say
about it which we will talk about
Patrick Stewart and Logan I think gives
the best performance in any x-men there
you go let's find it out Brian Cox it's
a great villain he is a really good
villain in x-men too but I think that if
you're going to the whole franchise
among if I'm picking out one specific
and individual performance
I just don't think comparatively he's
able to stand up to the even other
villain performances perhaps in this
series I think that he's a very strong
villain he's a very good actor they got
him for a reason but you know the
Stryker character I don't think came
back off the strength of his great
performance because he was established
as the guy that made Wolverine and you
went back in time and showed Wolverine
being made so you have to have Stryker
there because I've established him with
a million other characters but it's 34
years in advance you could just happen
like he was working the whole strikers
whole thing and his whole Pole in that
movie is he's the whole reason that
Wolverine does with each other next one
two is two strikers the guy saying like
you don't know what you are but I do
because I was there and I made you what
you are so you have to have striker
there because you've established that he
was there well strikers already a major
character in the comics it's not just
that he's a major kid like it's not just
excuse neither
kind of character in the comics then
they changed erratically for the films
largely based again on the setup of x2
and the power of this Brian Cox
performance and you're quoting the lines
of dialogue directly from x2 like yeah
you were always an animal I just gave
you a clause like it's it's this
incredibly sort of deep thoughtful
promoter and I mean the fact that
magneto is not truly he's the villain
but he's not really ability sort of back
and forth he's one of the protagonists
of this franchise I think you mean a guy
like Stryker to balance it out you need
a very strong compelling villain who
comes through a bunch of the movies and
it's all rooted in that Cox performance
from Part two I think it's all rooted
necessarily like in the writing and I
unfortunately I do think it's a great
performance I think that he makes a
fantastic villain I think it gets lost
in the shuffle I have to say x2 is one
of my favorites it might be my favorite
in this franchise I had to look up Brian
Cox because you had not put that he was
striker yeah wait your movie but because
it just gets lost in the shuffle but
there's so many other I don't know it's
a great performance that's a great but
I'm saying no I'm saying it's a great
performance but other like ultimately it
is not the best one in this franchise
because if it was it would be something
that would stick with me more I at least
like I didn't remember who Brian Cox was
but both of your arguments that feel
like you're going off of the fact that
just like I said in my opening that
we've seen these guys in a lot of other
movies and that's what gives this final
one or this other one the power like
European all your arm is like yeah we'll
we his superpowers is mine and we've
never seen this side before it's like
well yeah that that performance becomes
more meaningful when you think back on
all the other movies so I don't need
that you don't need to draw in the other
that's the thing is like Patrick Stewart
sells the tragedy of this situation
because Logan doesn't it doesn't even
tell you it doesn't even fully tell you
exactly what happened you see it through
that scene that cut it's like a
heartbreaking scene the heartbreaking
scene where he's where he's talking to
Logan and he says like this is one of
the best nights I've had in my life
but I don't deserve it and the grief
that he has you see this this broken man
it
the tragedy that he brings to that part
like I'm not even talking inside the
franchise look at that performance as a
whole and just this this this this man
who's fighting himself at the same time
is he's fighting the world around him
like not only is his mind battling
against him the world is coming to get
him and the weight that he gives that
the weight that you feel on this
character's shoulders like Brian Cox is
a great villain performance in an x-men
movie but Patrick Stewart as Xavier in
Logan that's just this just not it's not
limited to the x-men the idea of growing
old and your body turning against you
the idea of being a burden on other
people in the horror with that he plays
all of that so beautifully it's not one
note it's very it's it's subdued it's
humorous when it needs to be the the
shades that he gives that character and
it's not just oh I feel bad for
Professor X because I know who he is no
it's I feel bad for this person and I'm
glad you touched on the humor because I
love that performance I think it's
fantastic I do think at times the humor
is a little over the top and it takes me
out of it if you want to talk about
someone this is Magneto really he's not
necessarily relishing in what he has to
do he is a heartbroken person he feels
like he has been abandoned by all of the
people who were supposed to be helping
him to protect his people and that is
another you know you talk about getting
old and in dealing with age this is
someone who was dealing for he has seen
what has happened he is dealing for the
survival of his people and that's where
these fantastic speeches and he puts
he's able to do all of that because of
the strength of how Michael Fassbender
is acting in those he is restrained when
he needs to be restrained
he's over-the-top when he when he needs
to really pull it out and be villainous
and say to the world we're gonna show
you that yeah you should fear us we are
scary he can pull that out and go as big
and as large with that as he needs to or
he can be on a plane where literally
he's bringing everything in including
the plane and make it very personal
between him and Charles Xavier and yeah
a lot of that is their writing because
it's it's good writing on that movie but
a lot of that is you know the difference
between how Michael Fassbender can
either push it out or can bring it in
depending on what needs to happen okay
hany x-men let's shift gears and go to
our final thoughts lon you can continue
your here's a great actor he's a little
subdued in all three of those movies I
feel like those performances as magneto
are all kind a little bit flat they're
all a little subdued he never gets to
where Ian McKellen took the character
they're supposed to be playing the same
the same guy and different weights of
their life but McKellen has this very
broad very theatrical take on magneto
and we never really see Fassbender get
there it's always this very kind of he's
he's a raging fire but under the surface
he's very like subdued on the surface
and even that big speech is big moment
at the end of future passwords on TVs
gotta the cameras on them this is like
I'm gonna announce mutants to the world
we all gotta unite even that speech
which should be his big moment it's also
kind of subdued so I don't know it's a
little bit of a it's a little bit of a
low-key sort of take on magneto as for
all the Logan Professor X though I mean
I agree it's a good performance as a
sort of person who's experiencing sort
of senility dementia at the end of their
life we've seen a lot of great actors
take that kind of role on I think it's
almost like kind of at opposite ends
what you're saying like the the power of
that performance I think is the fact
that he is losing his grip he's losing
his mind so the idea that the weight of
all this stuff is on his shoulders what
sort of is it isn't he's not as aware of
the world around him it's sort of his
his coming apart and his sort of the
forgetting of who Charles Xavier was
that to me is the real power of that
performance but it's also kind of a side
feature in that movie I mean I really
think it's it's more of Hugh Jackman's
film so those are those are my final
thoughts Thank You lon
Danielle you know you talked about how
it restrained he is but I think that
what it is showing is that he is in
control because he is still that is his
ability to show that he still cares
about Charles he still cares about the
other mutants around him and he wants to
both show the world that I can do all
this powerful stuff and I don't have to
do it while calculating Minette
maniacally I can do it while being very
in control of my words and showing you
through my power who I am and it's also
a way for Fassbender to communicate that
he does still care about Charles and
that he does still care in the in that
way I also again I Patrick's to his
performance in that
is amazing some of the humor takes me
out of it times where he cursed I feel
like those are the ones that wind up
being the things that people remember
the most which is a shame because it's
it's a great performance but it's at a
few points he gets a little too hammy
I feel like he you know and Brian Cox
again fantastic performance really well
done but I just it doesn't rise - it
definitely doesn't rise - Patrick
Stewart and it certainly doesn't rise to
Michael Fassbender Thank You Danielle
yeah yeah like I said Brian Cox like a
very strong villain performance but I
just don't think it rises as they know
so to the weight of not just from a
performance level from a character level
to the significance and what these other
two represent in context of the series
in context of their own movies there are
a lot of great performances Alan [ __ ]
these great next men - by Ian McKellen
as always is great I think his is a good
performance in a movie full of good
performances I'm not saying it's bad
it's just like what makes that the one
that's the best out of all of them
Michael Fassbender I think is a good as
I like him as Magneto
but again why this performance in Days
of Future past specifically what does he
bring to that movie specifically I could
all of the things that you said about
his performance as a magneto I agree but
you could have said that about his
performance as magneto in x-men first
class even his performance is maybe you
are next when apocalypse when he really
does lose everything
I think he's good in all of the movies
that specific performance does it stand
out to me just because he has several
ones the reason that I picked Patrick
Stewart out of all of the performances
is that is one that is singular to that
movie it both brings closure to that
characters for long to that character of
Xavier for longtime fans for people that
just went to see it because it's the
r-rated Wolverine movie
he's accessible because he does bring
those elements of aging and growing old
you don't need to know the entire
history of that character to understand
where he's coming from the idea that
he's not as aware of the world that's
how his character starts because he has
to be drugged because he has to be doped
up but you need to dull his senses but
at you know he that as the movie goes on
he stops saying as medicine and that's
what drives the plot is that he he
becomes more aware of the world he
realizes that not all hope is lost
that's what makes that's what gives that
performance a little of the depth and
layer and that's ultimately the track
things that he's cut down as this hope
is brought back to the world I think
that's just the evolution of this
character the cursing the humor I mean
again I think that's what makes it so
realistic which is that you know that is
part of growing older is you lose your
filter you start cursing maybe a little
bit more than you did when you were
younger you you maybe are a little bit
more inappropriately humorous in time so
it doesn't call for it that's part of
the aging process that's that's just
again another layer to that character I
think it goes beyond just this is a
great character in the franchise it's
it's this is a great performance it's so
multi level he's getting so much to do
and I think it stands out more so than
any other one and any other movie I
think it's a fantastic performance not
just a great character
all right time there you go three very
different choices here can take us to
the fact zone well I think a lot of the
facts were on the up and up just looking
on Twitter there Carly and says I mean
and puts a picture of Wolverine from
Logan it's very brave of Dan when
talking about Logan and not choosing
Logan but we'll see if that came out Jew
back a defense my old friend from the TV
fights day says wait up change my answer
it's Eric with Saul from Logan as far as
facts I'll take that Danielle Brian Cox
is born in Dundee UK in 1946 he's list
is 5 feet 9 inches tall 2001 nominated
for a Primetime Emmy for his guest
appearance on Frasier lawns Brian Cox
impressions rated 92% accurate on Rotten
crushinator
and was a play by Danny Huston and Josh
Helman every other fact put out there it
was pretty darn good all right Ken thank
you for that mix of facts thoughts
tweets and other info presentations
yes Brian Cox does a fine job on HBO's
succession by the way if you like
billions try billions light succession
um Billy it's good do you want to know
the results before you job no I will
tell you though that I spent most this
time for some reason YouTube thinks that
Fassbender is a bad word so we really so
yeah I thought these were some great
choices and lon I I thought you that was
a bold choice and you're breaking down
the motivations of that character really
got me thinking that much more about
that strong performance so I I think
it's a it's a bold choice but not a bad
one Danielle I I liked were you going
with Fassbender that and like some of
the speeches but at the end of the day I
heard the most specificity and a
combination of where the character was
at in his trajectory long got a good
ding on the notion of this choice with
okay but you need the entire body of
work and him arriving at this place but
I thought Dan you cemented it and and
just like that like those heartbreaking
moments like yeah the one of the best
nights of my life that's scene after
they you know that dinner and everything
so it was a beautiful performance and
Dan I thought you stuck the landing on
that so I go Dan Ken where are your
songs page I mean it is Logan look I
listen to everything as best I could was
rating Lon's impression of Brian Cox
could usual on say he's the worst
student we've got is the worst student
we've got that's perfect now up to 95%
on the right pressures me
have to work on that I waited all the
way to the end and I really did I gotta
say I love what Dan said about bringing
it home by Fassbender he's definitely
great but you could make me pick one or
two of his other performances Brian Cox
good bold choice lon didn't convinced me
that it was memorable above the other
ones what Patrick Stewart did bring that
character home that connected with me
when Dan talked about that character's
legacy come to a close in that role even
though if some of the film's might go on
we'll see who knows in the franchise
filmmaking these days but I I went with
Dan on that one all right Dan you get
the point
all right Billy what did the poll have
to say what a mistake I made this was
this wasn't even close at 83% Patrick
Stewart for Logan 9% for Fassbender and
6% of Brian Cox here's a really fun fact
Stewart for Luke Wow strong performance
was on the table for us all to take our
second choices but one fouled out New
York actually I recently relaunched all
the x-men movies for a video that we
were doing and I was really impressed
going back with the Brian cuts weird so
I was glad to get the opportunity to
talk about their performance I think
it's an unsung yeah comic book movie if
someone got to talk about Patrick
Stewart doing it cuz like and also you
know how can you leave my favorite
Fassbender scene is when he goes to I
think was Argentina to kill the Nazis
and you would think I forgot that scene
is entirely in German oh yeah
Oh such a great scene all right Dan the
man is up
zero if you guys want I your revenge ten
cinnamon we better start putting points
on the board get revenge nice like
Maggie around okay question numero dos
and you can be Magneto
I think you're already magneto question
numero dos Blum houses next horror film
will be about an evil magic 8-ball we
asked what haunted object would inspire
the best horror film
what haunted object would inspire the
best horror film question number two
let's start with player number two
Danielle so for me we're doing household
objects you know I thought about things
like swords which for some people who
are sword kids that is something that
you would pick weight sword kids is a
thing sorta sword dudes is a thing okay
oh yeah guys who have like yeah yeah
yeah my mom is a sword taste caliber so
I picked when I was thinking what is
something that could potentially ruin
your life without being haunted and can
extra ruin your life with being haunted
and I picked an Internet router because
nothing can be more life-ruining than
the Internet I imagine a movie wearing
your your internet router is now haunted
and it becomes like a haunted version of
rough breaks the Internet where people
can get sucked in they can get taken out
you know you can wind up being sucked
into the internet yourself or something
can come out you know this evil this
haunted demon whatever this is can take
the form of whatever it can find on the
Internet which is basically everything I
basically cheated I'm done
alright a haunted Ralph breaks the
internet very intriguing Thank You
Danielle damn I also picked something
that's already very scary and already
and already a menace II scooters
[Laughter]
scooters picture this this is the
opening scene of the movie made in two
young kids riding as you should not to
two at a time on a nice scooter on the
sidewalk they're having the time of
their lives all of a sudden it starts
swerving off to the left they look at
each other stop doing it I'm not doing
that get a hold of it nobody knows
before you know it BAM
right in the middle of a bus right in
just headfirst in road why are you on a
scooter czar Menace when used properly
can you imagine the ghost of a jogger
run down in cold blood by a group of
teenagers on a scooters comes back to
wipe out those even not even the ones
that actually took them took them down
but to wipe out the entire Menace of
people on East scooters and the thing is
it's not just writing these scooters you
can be walking down the street you could
be parked in your car you could be
inside if you live in an apartment
building I promise you there's an e
scooter inside your building somewhere
because people take them and they get
paid to charge them and they put them
back on the street they're everywhere
and they're coming after you alright the
troubled ghost of enough a jogger long
so scooters plays definitely 2jt we know
has a background I picked something that
I know is near too dear to both Billy
and Ken's hearts and that's vaping if
you will a haunted vape pen now every
time that you blow a cloud of smoke out
of there vapor excuse me out of this
vape pen you're releasing a demon into
the world that has to kill you within
seven days now you're being haunted by
this thing that you brought into the
world like that's the that great
dramatic irony we love in horror films
is that these people they're bringing it
themselves they're sort of felt they are
the ones who blew the dank cloud in the
first place and now that dead cloud is
following them around the city trying to
kill them and that actually I want to
call the movie it would look like the
title is dank clouds but then you do
that horror movie where it gets all
staticky for a second and it turns into
dark clouds yeah mess scape your vape Oh
coming this fall Wow okay and all three
of these blow my mind let's fight it out
I just want to say not part of the fight
the scream og movie I think that's what
we call it's the same with a lot of the
sort of the later Nightmare on Elm
Street films it's too open it's too
fantastical once you can suck people
into the internet you could do literally
anything yeah it's too hard to turn that
into a compelling like three-act story
there's no there's no dramatic intensity
because any moment they could turn a
corner and literally anything can happen
it's the same with the Freddy Krueger
movies where eventually it's not that
scary because my arm is just gonna come
out of this washer/dryer and kill it
it's not only just being able to come in
and out so for one thing it's scary
because you have to use the internet
there's no way around it you don't have
to use bird scooters although everyone
keeps asking what acting like you do you
gotta be around them no oh yeah but you
know you don't have to use one of those
please stop but when this one they're
three acts are very simple you get the
evil router you're very happy to move
into your new home and then you put in
your evil router and so act one all of a
sudden weird things started happening
around the house oh my god why is my
credit union calling me why do I
suddenly have all of this money in my
account and the cops are coming to get
me terrifying is the worst
but then in act 2 where things start
getting kind of dark and weird at that
point all of a sudden everyone around
you they're things start getting start
getting affected in the world becomes
affected this thing is made itself into
a demon virus that could hop four
mounted a router then act three then you
go into the internet because that is how
you have to solve it you have to
shut it down leaping and bounding from
Twitter tweet to tweet to tweet to tweet
I'm just hopping over um and going
around and debate me the villains are
like internet memes and content describe
to the actual emoji movie I'm pretty
sure that's actually the 4G hotspot
unplug your router your problem is
solved that's the thing is there's many
more ways to go I just go to the library
because there's a haunted routers
libraries books are great a haunted vape
pen I you know that's interesting but I
feel like the thing that doesn't make it
quite as scary for me is that you are
you are in a way you're the instrument
of your own destruction yeah it's
because of your own I think once once we
have enough time to haunt the - to study
what vaping is being killed by the by
the vapor ghosts you're really just
moving up the inevitable it being like
haunted cigarettes it's in the mind of
the audience it's just like well you
could just quit and then there's not a
problem just not watch the Ring video -
but you don't know in advance that's the
whole that's the whole thing you've done
it to yourself but because of your
ignorance well I think also the problem
is is that part of part of what we love
about horror movies and part of the
suspense is there are always gonna be
people that we want to not die I want
everyone who vapes clouds real deep to
die the one person who it's their first
time trying vaping they don't like it
but now they're cursed
there's your hero and yeah everybody
else it's fun to see them get picked up
that's the slasher movie credo you know
I want to see all these teens in the
woods get it and as for the birds
goodness it's a little too close you're
basically doing Birdemic it's it's the
bird in the name it's like maximum
creature feature it's just the swarm of
things and they're chasing everybody and
it's like we've seen it a million times
doing it with scooters is a little
different we've seen it with vehicles
we've seen it with critters and we have
seen
the attorney we haven't seen ghost
movies one-hundredth we have not have a
perk loud turns into a demon the goat
vapor clouds that's what they are we
check on this ghost made of ectoplasm
hotcakes are ghosts real China but the
East coder thing it's about the
collateral damage it's about the fact
that it you know you don't you it's that
it's not something that you use you
you're not gonna picked off because you
use something you're gonna pick up
because somebody else did some good
somebody else use something that's what
scares the villain just faceless swarms
of scooters kind of like it's kind of
like a fallen but imagine instead of the
ghosts passing between John Goodman and
people it's from a scooter the scooter
[Music]
know which one it is and they're all
faceless there's 20 of them lined up oh
it's one of them evil are none of them
evil you don't know you can try to
escape but anyway you try to go that
scooter could be right there just one
bird scooters not really that scary
sjt with one bird scooter my friend that
were plenty scary for me you know what's
scary for me what's scary for me is wave
someone having the ability to ruin my
credit forever if someone's gonna do
that I don't want to be a demon I want
it to be me what haunted everyday object
would inspire the best psychological
thriller let's uh move to final thoughts
please thoughts again unfortunately both
of these these movies Wow I would
honestly watch either of them for either
one of them the premise of people on
bird scooters getting straight-up merked
I definitely would not there wouldn't be
suspenseful for me because I would be
like literally any day now same with
everybody who is vaping it's just a hey
can we I want to like do the deaths and
then we can we can peace out with this
being able to be a haunted router means
that you can it opens up so many
possibilities for stories there's any of
the things that I talked about again you
can get things where the router takes
you know it takes the the form of
someone that's on the internet the
router comes in and maybe it looks like
your mom I don't know and so because
you're able to expand it I think that it
is more friendly for franchises which
we're all trying to do now you want to
get at least three movies out of it and
so I think that the haunted the hunted
rapper wouldn't be the way to I can't
even say it without laughing alright
Danielle already has her eyes on a
beauty universe
nice damn yeah I mean I think that this
ideally it is spooky yeah the black
mirror like it's an emoji movie and kids
movies are taking on this theme now I
just don't see a whole lot of
originality that's not gonna seem like a
rehash of something we've seen and saw
TV and several different other things
even you know like just ghost in the
machine
type thing yeah I mean I just feel like
that's well-tried and ground with the
vape pen again it's it's a ghost movie
but I just don't I I don't see the like
what's the what's the hook other than
like like the delivery system is
different but it then it's just a ghost
movie you know I'm like I said I don't
necessarily think that all people in
vapor should die you know it's it's
better than walking through a cloud
smoke okay I gotta be honest if I have
to choose between walking through a
cherry-flavored cloud of vape and a wall
of cigarette smoke I'll choose the
Cherry Bay police doesn't smell terrible
the thing with the birds scooters is or
the lime scooters or whatever kind of
scooters that you're gonna use and maybe
it's all of them is the fact that they
are everywhere there they all look
exactly the same and you never know
which one is gonna be and you can't get
away from it by not you can get away
from by not vaping you can avoid it by
not using the internet router you can't
get away from the bird or the lime or
the e-scooter by not using it because
they're everywhere so you can run but
guess what you're playing right into its
hands if you run because then you're in
motion and that's where the e scooter
thrives my friends this is a villain
that you cannot escape from that can
actively catch up with you it could take
out your friends it could take out total
strangers you never know it's kinda like
death and final destination who knows
where it's coming from but you might be
next
faceless alright they're coming after
you wherever you run long one big issue
with that talk about the Easter is this
they're not everywhere they're in major
urban centers if you live in a rural
area in the Midwest your town is not
overrun with these scooters which also
gives this that's a kind of a fatal flaw
just like it follows for people like
we'll just fly to Europe and then it'll
take the year it follows forever to find
you well just go
somewhere in Montana where there aren't
really scooters that scooter is gonna
take forever how fast they travel 12
miles an hour it's gonna take you take
that scooter forever to get to you and
also I think the facelessness is a prom
there's there's not a villain for us to
latch onto it is the same kind of wrong
with these faceless horror movies where
it's just like it's hard to get too
invested in this scenario because there
is a compelling horror villain it kind
of hurts you in terms of the franchise
with the Internet again I just feel like
it's too open there's a million scary
things on the Internet we've had haunted
websites we've had haunted stuff in your
phone we've got all this haunted
technology I think you need a really
drill into like what's the scary thing
on the internet that were actually
freaked out by and like sort of drill
into that more I actually think a
haunted modem like coming to life and
chasing you might be scarier than
getting stuck in a haunted Internet now
as for the vaping the thing that is so
it's universally relatable everybody
knows some guy vapes in their town and I
think you've got a lot of jumping off
for future franchises like what part of
the vape is haunted is it the juice
that's what is it they the battery
that's wanted is it a function of its
own there's all sorts of stuff to
investigate the nature of these ghosts
once they come out and they're ghosts
once they come out they have
personalities maybe there are other
people who souls got sucked in by the
vapor you've got a nemesis you've got
somebody to sort of aim the movie you've
got somebody who needs to be defeated
and I think that's sort of at the core
of what makes these kinds of movies fun
damn time
there you go first off I want to
apologize to all of our audience that
babe keep vaping your we'd keep vaping
your tobacco god bless you I have one
for you
ghost dabs yeah
okay can please chime in with facts and
give us your opinion on this round well
fought round I love movie pitch rounds
very good I went to the Internet to find
some facts forty years ago Consumer
Reports ran an article saying that there
have been eight deaths tied to e-scooter
since 2017 lucky 16 NPR article says
ghosts might be made of dark matter and
dark energy question Kevin Jackson on
Twitter watching the show says uh I like
the idea of the haunted vape pen they
can double as an ad campaign against
vaping because it brings demons it can
kill you
as far as you plot someone to Danielle's
there might be some similarities per day
emoji movie costs fifty million to make
and it made two hundred seventeen point
eight million at the box office but may
in terms of on the pitch I I love pitch
in movies it's one of the only times I
win points our movie fights unless I'm
drunk Danielle put together a realistic
three act movie that I could believe in
I like the other ideas pitched your
dance come back up hey you know unplug
the router but hey you can step over the
scooter like JC should have done a year
ago you know we don't want to cast
aspersions too much on papers I mean
kind of but I'm going with Danielle all
right that's one for Danielle yeah I
thought these were all fun pitches yeah
Danielle's uh once we started getting
into going around the internet it also
reminded me what was that film with John
Ritter where he went into cable stay
tuned
he's getting yeah it was harkening back
to stay tuned so I liked elements of of
that and yeah Dan had some some fun
imagery I like that there was a ghost of
this specifically the ghost of this
jogger but at the end of the day I was I
really started to gravitate towards lon
just the fact that we I think that your
your dig on him Danielle he turned it
around
we got the douchiest it's like these
deaths that you love to hate there's
something just juicy about that and then
when he was talking about Oh which part
is it like is there an evil company
putting out this vape juice you got me
thinking silver shamrock yes yeah it was
all fun but I just barely I gotta go on
so we have one for Danielle one for lawn
Billy what's happening over on the poles
is the air case this one was a lot
closer than the last one at 51% the
internet goes with lawn and the bait
pain at 30 30 percent these numbers
never really added I was like carry the
for 30 percent Internet router and an
only 17 percent we have a lot of jte
movie thinkers that do not want to see
yes a repeat of the scooter those
scooters to make it to your toe there's
really expensive litter I always find
them like right in front of my apartment
they're not even supposed to be like
because the popularity is Crested but
they just keep putting more of them on
the street so different brands oh and
now there's like a little motorized
bicycle and stuff yeah I really had the
worst I hate it
yeah technology it's jump the shark okay
JT
on the mend Dan Wan Wan WAN Danielle
looking to get on the board question
number three here she comes
so rumor has it the new Batman will face
off against the penguin so we asked in
Matt Reeves movie who should take on the
role of Oswald Cobblepot who should be
the penguin and this is question three
we start with player three Dan I like
the penguin I only seen him in one movie
he's been in several TV shows and
cartoons animated series of stuff but
the penguin we only know that Danny
DeVito penguin cinematically so we've
had that one take the actor and I listed
a lot of different ones the one that
really stuck with me that I kept coming
back to is a Kenneth Branagh Kenneth
Branagh unknown is that he's a director
but he's also a quite the actor if you
may not know him he's does more than
directs for he is I should experience
after he has been blockbuster films
blockbuster movies he's been in smaller
movies and the reason that I picked
Kenneth Branagh is I want to see the
side of the penguin that was the
background was hinted at in the Danny
DeVito version that we've seen
cinematically but they didn't really go
into this version of the actual
character and the way that I would like
to see the match up which is that we
have Robert Pattinson as a young Batman
which also means a young Bruce Wayne and
what I love about Oswald Cobblepot and
what you can go into is not this
creature from the sewers that rises to
the top but this guy who is entrenched
in the aristocracy and the upper-class
of Gotham City because because Oswald
Cobblepot this from a rich background he
has money he has wealth and so I want to
see a version of the penguin who
basically already runs the world that
Bruce Wayne is coming into and I think
the upside of that is not only can
Batman do battle against the penguin but
Bruce Wayne as his family's old money
but Bruce Wayne is new money Bruce Wayne
is really just when he becomes Batman
coming into this world and we've always
seen in the movies he's always like kind
of shunned the playboy side of himself
like unless he's George Clooney with the
model on his arm but this idea that
that Batman can battle the penguin both
ends in and out of costume that you can
have this penguin that's at the top of
the ladder and this is a big challenge
for both Batman and Bruce Wayne I think
that's a really fun way to paint those
characters and to establish that we have
a younger Batman so Kenneth Branagh I
think you know of course you'll do a
little prosthetic work but I don't want
to go in the full like stringy hair
black goop coming out of the mouth that
we had Danny DeVito doing like I want
this kind of wealthy upper-crust version
of the penguin for Batman and Bruce
Wayne to battle and I think Kenneth
Branagh would be really good at that
part all right Dan pitching a goop free
penguin around the horn along so I
picked an actor very different again
like Dan I like I'd like to get away
from the freakish monstrous penguin that
we got I love Batman Returns I love that
take on it but I think we've seen that
and it would be interesting there's a
lot of shades to this character one of
the things I think is so interesting
about the penguin is his self view the
way he sees himself is so different from
the rest of the world and how he's
perceived he sees himself as kind of
this as the gentleman of crime but this
this aristocratic wealthy captain of
industry but the restaurant he's he's a
scumbag I mean he owns a you know he
owns a nightclub and he's a criminal
he's a crook and I think that a guy that
I think could really capture that
arrogance and that disconnect of not
understanding how the world sees him is
Jason Schwartzman I think we've seen him
in the past
he can play crafty he could play clever
he could play like I think I'm the
smartest guy in the room all of which I
think really fits us what kompot serve
as well but he's really got that like
he's a weasel and everybody else sort of
thinks he's a weasel but he doesn't know
it he's kind of floating above that
perception of him we've seen him do that
in many West Anderson films and also it
feels like sort of listen up Philip and
so these other indie roles that he's
played and marie-antoinette even as well
and I think that that same version of
sort of Jesus core sort of what he does
but in the world of Gotham playing this
character would be a really interesting
different taking the character and also
age wise I think it's a really good mix
for Pat so he feels like a pier for the
Robert Pattinson character that would be
sort of believable to have them face off
lon coming in with Jason Schwartzman
Danielle um so I'm glad that we all kind
of agree that you know is
is that Danny DeVito version is and
everyone knows that's like close to my
heart we don't want to get away from
that there are so many great aspects of
penguin you've all you've mentioned a
lot of them for me I'm really into the
idea that not only the gentlemen of
crime he's a mob boss he is where he
runs the Mafia and I feel like that's
something that we've really gotten away
from in a lot of these movies and I like
aside from having me know the big Joker
the explosions all of those things just
like that real Gotham is a city of crime
and I think the best person that would
be able to pull that off would be Brian
Tyree Henry who a lot of people
unfortunately only know as paperboy even
though he's like a great actor yeah he's
a fantastic actor he has a lot of range
and I fully believe that he could pull
off being this intelligent like
incredibly smart gentleman mob boss who
you would also be terrified of if he you
know with one look but who could also be
incredibly charming because oz what
Cobblepot is a very charming character
all right Daniel coming in with Brian
Tyree Henry fight it out
Jason Schwartzman he's done I mean he is
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world he literally
owns a nightclub he's a super villain
he's smarmy he's in the living he's done
that I've seen that flavor from him
before and I don't I just don't see the
the I think Daniel I both are working on
a different level so you look at the
intimidation factor
mm-hmm they're like fix things like up
here like I don't want to see Batman
fight up here I don't want to see
somebody who's like on the same level as
Batman especially if he's new like I
want to see someone who is his superior
because that to me is what makes it an
interesting fight it's not really the
penguin I mean the pill that of all the
Gotham rogues gallery like like that me
doesn't really like knock-down drag-out
fights against the penguin it's it's
sort of through proxies or its it's a
different level so I don't think you
need the physically imposing in fact I
almost feel like that cuts against me I
just mean like an actual pier like
another young guy like I I don't it's
not as interesting to me as as opposed
to someone who's got more experience
who's not another young upstart like
he's there he's already there that's
what bat
really is about its its getting rid of
the entrenched villainy that's
definitely a take I think there cuz
these are malleable stories they're
gonna be a lot of different takes I mean
you could definitely have a the penguin
has been a longtime mob boss who's been
running things in Gotham City for
decades but you can also have like the
penguin is a relatively new guy on the
scene who's climbing the criminal ladder
have gotten to spent four seasons doing
that penguin from the ground up he
starts as a little level mob guy and
goes to the top even people that didn't
like Gotham a lot of them the one thing
they took away from it was that they
liked the penguin and they liked that
actor they liked the character they like
that portrayal so I think that's a
double bead on what we just saw with the
penguin which is the rise through crime
especially for Batman fans think they
might have something I mean the problem
Kenneth Branagh is it's too much like
that's who the penguin sees himself as
you're playing so much into that image
and it almost doesn't feel recognizable
as the character I mean he's got to be
ridiculous on some level like he's the
penguin it's it's maybe Batman's most
ridiculous nemesis and I think if you
lose that entirely and you know when
eyes it to the point I'm not doing that
you're saying that I'm doing that but
I'm not if you don't think Kenneth
Branagh can play ridiculous arts ville
and go watch wild wild west but that's
the movie is tennis Kenneth Branagh
knows exactly what's going on he knows
the excess that's going on around them
the problem was that nobody else in the
movie note knew what was going on its
taxi that's incredibly cartoonish and
broad which I were saying that my choice
was to know this can too dark and gritty
and I'm telling you I didn't want him to
do it but I'm saying the Kenneth Branagh
can play the other note is what I'm
saying is the you where you were trying
to say that my choice was to wild wild
les proves that Kenneth Branagh can play
bigger I think it proves he sort of
misses the mark when he tries and it
becomes
ludicrous and almost unwatchable no I
disagree again watch that perform I mean
I would say to the audience go back and
watch wild wild west to see which side
that you fall
you're gonna say you guys have to go
dude it's 9b I'm not saying he's one of
the big marks against that man you're
not saying he should replicate what he
did unless I'm just saying you were
saying by pick was not good because
that's you were putting a direction on
it that I don't want to take playing
like Poirot in the the orient-express
recently like that's a big colorful
character and he's still under playing
it and I mean that's great Kenneth Brown
is a great actor I like what he does a
lot but I don't maybe not for the
penguin I think there's so many like
he'd be an amazing Raja yeah a character
that I would that I would liken it more
toward is what he did in the Harry
Potter movies
Gilderoy Lockhart he's a big guy he has
a public face he puts on a big show but
behind that there's another level that
you don't know about until afterwards
he's a coward he's a fraud he's a phony
and again not replicating that
performance but that's what I mean is
Kenneth Branagh can play bigger
characters with more underneath them
that isn't just darken 6-pin King
Macbeth I think people just think of
Shakespeare when they think of Kenneth
Branagh and he's capable of doing so
much more than that
Brian Tyree Henry I think again it goes
down to what characterization is more
interesting to you and I mean that's
just a debate that every we all have
three have different characterizations
for me I think it's more interesting to
have a characterization of the penguin
that's less as you said like terrifying
with one look hmm and more like
terrifying because no one sees how evil
he is and you have to fight not only
that person but public opinion and
public perception which is another
vitamin which I do think is super
interesting I think that's a great take
these are all great takes listen to be
real but with it does come down there is
a certain point in every one of these
movies where you have to take the hero
and you have to take the villain and
they got to be staring each other down
and something has to happen it doesn't
necessarily have to be a punch fest or
any of that but at a certain point you
have to get these two in a room and I
would like it so that when you do
finally get our Pat's
our bats into a room with the penguin it
isn't one of these things where it's
like oh well he's gonna do that
a little weaselly dude you know he's
gonna knock him out with one punch it
might not even be a fight but I want it
to feel like it could be believable that
these two people might be able to you
square off against each other or it
might be a war of words which you know I
like you're taken and like what you're
doing I do feel like we already saw
maybe not exactly that but a version of
that in Batman vs Superman which I
thought that that was a good
characterization I didn't like it be
that wasn't Jesse Jesse Eisenberg it
wasn't like quite like Lex Luthor II but
I thought that it was a fun
interpretation of that but I feel like
we have already gotten that with one of
these major villains and so I want to
try something that's a little new Brian
Terry Henry he can give you Shakespeare
if you need to he can be he can be paper
boy if you need him to he can be a fun
dad if you need him to and I think those
are the the qualities and all these are
great actors but I feel like those are
the qualities where he can give people
something that they're not going to be
expecting because so many people think
of him as paper boy and they don't
really know that he's you know this
actor who's been on Broadway like
nominated for Tony's people don't know
that he's an amazing actor and so I
think that he could also be a surprise
where it's something where he could do
something with the penguin where the
penguin is able to be malleable and
change personalities for depending on
where he's at if he is a craft shift
gears and go to thoughts rival ones from
Dan
starting off yeah again different
approaches and everyone has their
favorite approach but what makes Kenneth
Branagh on the penguin and this take on
the penguin more interesting to me is
again we've seen Batman fight against
people's own age his peers I mean that's
a lot of the the Nolan verse he was
mostly were people his own age or people
that were around the same age as him
even the Joker and it's a turd scarecrow
and then with Brian Terry Henry we just
got a great boss little kingpin type
like that with instance in Opera who's
the kingpin who was a guy who was at the
top of the mob and ran the mob but was
also very physically intimidating and
considering with one look that was a
great beat to have and you know that
people might respond to that in a Batman
movie but I think something that what
you want with these new Batman movies is
something new
fresh take something new and something
different and what I think kenneth
branagh brings is the kind of Menace
that you get from someone who maybe
can't scare you with one look or maybe
doesn't have the youth and the vigor of
someone on the rise but is somebody who
has the arsenal of power behind them and
I think that Kenneth Branagh can can
play those shades he can he can do the
the public face I think he can do the
villainous stuff and he doesn't have to
go as far as Wild Wild West that was an
example to say like he's not dark and
brooding he has many different shades
from every side of the spectrum
available at his disposal as an actor
and it's really combination of the actor
and the take I like to take on the
penguin something different something
new for Batman cinematically and also an
actor that I think would fit that that
approach for these new movies Branagh
Dan Rather horn along I think one of the
things that I would like to capture the
pin I don't think we captured before and
then the DeVito version that I think
it's so great and interesting about this
character is that that clash that
awkward sort of juxtaposition of a guy
personally is a little weaselly as a
little nebbishy but who is also
brilliant enough and strong enough and
vicious enough to rise in this Gotham
underworld and become the penguin and I
think that's what jason schwartzman
we've seen him a bunch of times that the
arrogant guy may be in over his death
who's pushing through it may be sort of
awkwardly or uncomfortably we've seen
her do that really well and a bunch of
other things we see that he can sort of
take on a comic book role as as a guy
who's in this world and sort of do it
believably and I think that that would
be a really interesting sort of basis to
start with this character I think these
are both great actors and great choices
I don't mean to knock either of these
guys the thing with Brian Terry Henry
he's got this cool he's got this
charisma even in a villain role I know
you guys are widows he's amazing in that
and it's he's the bad guy he's the heavy
but he's not that the terrifying heavier
that's Daniel booyah
he's the like almost likable like I want
to be on this guy's side even though
he's baddie and I feel like that's kind
of wrong because I shouldn't feel like I
kind of want to be on the peg aside I
should find him like load some on some
level I think that that element of what
to Vito did I would want to keep
the sort of the thing for Branagh is I
feel like when he plays that level of
awkward when he plays kind of nebbishy
it doesn't always play you get like
celebrity that Woody Allen movie you get
Mike dead again which is a great movie
but I don't love his performance in it I
don't think it's he's not sort of great
at that kind of middle ground he's great
at these sort of sly subdued heroes and
he's great at the Shakespeare stuff I
don't I don't know if he necessarily
hits what I would see for the point I
feel like there's a lot of Batman
villains we could give him that might be
like a better tighter fit so that's why
I'm going with Jason Schwartzman Thank
You Schwartzman Danielle
so with Schwartzman again I will great
choices I don't and it does depend on
the take I do feel that he could do you
know kind of the the smarmy but when I
think of the penguin I don't necessarily
think of someone who is smarmy or who
has more confidence in himself that he
is competent the penguin is scary
confident that's how come he is able to
be a dude who looks like the penguin and
talks like the penguin and is able to be
as destructive in Gotham City as he is
with Kenneth Branagh I appreciate that
you want to do something a little bit
new maybe not have someone who was on
his age I do think that that is
something that we did get to see a
little bit of in Batman Begins so it's
not brand brand new granted there was
you know he has a fountain he goes in
and he gets young whatever it's not
brand brand new whereas I feel like it
is something that is really new with
brand Thierry Henry he isn't very cool
in every role he was not cool as a dad
and spider-verse and he was terrifying
as the warlord in Book of Mormon and so
but I like that he can be either one of
those things on a dime I think that that
when you have a character who can be
either charming or cool if they need to
be like genuinely cool really cool and
then have them be terrifying when they
need to be I think that that's a new
element and I think that that would be
something that would work really well
with the Penguins character who is
someone who is rich is wealthy is upper
crust or considers himself to be very
upper crust but is also dealing with the
lowest of the low as essentially a mob
boss in Gotham City which is the lowest
of the low of cities time there you go
Danielle with bth good - thank you guys
naps are what do we got in the facts
that was really good fighters I had one
another being swayed by each of them
there in terms of facts Pamela calls
himself the gentleman of crime we'll
come back to that later hair lawn
picking two cast members from one of my
favorite films Rushmore bonus point
swordsman thirty-eight hats Pattinson 33
Brad Pitt still 55 Ryan Tyree Henry 37
Branagh 60 born in Belfast Northern
Ireland directed Keanu Reeves in 1993 as
much ado about nothing
choices Brian Knight on Twitter says
Andy Serkis Jack Shipley our old friend
Jack who I do believe I still have a
restraining order against the Penguins
doesn't have to be played by a man I
like that Viola Davis in the role she
can just for weird facts Danny DeVito 48
Michael Keaton 41 during Batman Returns
wild wild west has a 17% of tomato Mito
tomato meter and Brian Tyree honey not
nominated 2018 for Tony in the film and
the play lobby here now as far as my
choices you want that now you know what
we run things a little different
so I like said at one point another
everyone had me convinced I love the
penguin that Dan was describing and in
lawns closing remarks he kind of talked
me out of Schwartzman by accident by
what he was saying then it comes down to
Danielle and and Dan and by a smidge you
both got but it shows great performers
great facts to support up I just liked
the penguin Dan was describing so it's
almost not even the choice I think
Branagh can fit that better and I wanted
that and Dan convince me of that penguin
right on I too liked the way Dan
described the penguin fitting into that
world Bruce Wayne going tit-for-tat with
someone not just on the hero villain
level but on the real life on the
streets of Gotham
you know one on the streets one the
sheets
I thought there was some some blows that
land and it's just as far as I don't
know for lack of a better term like just
I don't know Branagh brings a little bit
of a foo Phoenix to some of his
portrayal I don't know like governor
Lockhart is foofy yeah you gotta give
him at least and I'm not sure I don't
know I get called into question and me I
Danielle I thought made a great point
with harkening because I was thinking
this and she nailed it with the
Eisenberg and Batman V Superman that
tone it's very similar there and it
worked you know in fits and starts in
the no jars full of urine and strike
again but the more I thought about
Danielle because Brian Tyree Henry he's
an actor who everything I've seen him in
he loses himself in the role he's so
believable and just as far as the actor
like Ken I mean Dan had points for just
the plot breakdown of where he thought
Braniff fit in the world lon had some
stuff as far as like the ages as well
but yeah I I don't know I am most
intrigued by Danielle's choice and she
got me most interested so I'm going
Danielle so it's one for dad one for
Daniela two poles
yeah I'm just getting the most
up-to-date one after still have to
approve Fassbender comments thanks guys
this was a closer one and it was going
back and forth a lot but ultimately at
49% Dan with Kenneth Branagh down to 32%
with Danielle's choice with Brian Tyree
Henry and at 16 or 18 I can't see it
percent doesn't matter Jason Schwartzman
alright I'm just happy to let people
know that paperboy is a good actor I
know at this point some people don't
like great movies
some people really don't know they
really just think that he is like but he
goes away he's great as Paperboy same
here nominated for Tony's and Emmys and
I feel like people don't give him his
due absolutely no I like resonates truth
and like whatever role he dropped him in
he's freaking great
Danielle you're freaking great but I'm
sorry it's just Dan and lon
going into the speed round here Dan is
up two points to one and let's get fast
again I will ask the question calling
your answers you have 20 seconds to
elaborate on your answer and then we'll
go for 10 second rebuttals in the same
order once again Dan is up two points to
one first question of the speed round
secret life of pets - is opening we ask
what movie animal or creature would make
the best pet what movie animal or
creature would make the best pet
the shadow from homeward-bound
shadow from homeward bound the goose
that lays golden eggs from Willy Wonka &
the Chocolate sect
okay we got the golden goose shadow
we heard shadow from homeward bound
first Dan 20 seconds ago me speak first
of all shadow was a good dog he's a good
good dog he is loyal he is a leader if
for if the worst happens if he's lost or
if you're separated he will find his way
home to you and that's what I want in a
pet I'm a loyal T I want somebody that's
that I can come home to at the end of
the day that if the worst happens they
will find their way back to me it's
security I mean you got a pet you got a
responsibility you should be thinking
about your pedicures or what happens if
I lose it you hang onto that pack and if
we're talking about the pets that you're
gonna make sure that you're responsible
and you're hanging on to your pet what
would be better than a goose I'm
interested in what my pet can give what
I can give my pet not what my pet can
give me and if you been around geese
they're mean man I want a pet that I can
make a pet that I can come with I don't
know sit next to me on the couch now
that I just want more it can give me the
question was not what depends do you
want is your only pet dog
[Applause]
you know blonde coming in in his first
round and you know what I mean
he made some good points there I got it
abandoned the dog in real life I think
you'd be a fantastic pet owners I am
round you know good Billy as a business
venture I'm all in on the golden who's
trained by its best pet and I think in
terms of Dan laid out for me a better
argument about why shadow would make a
better pet rather than a moneymaker
while I go enjoy other pets so I'm going
with Dan Billy you made that make some
sense it's one one Ken look at best best
pet I Dan laid out what makes a good pet
while you want a pet lawn laid out a
good business plan if you have a
mortgage or something in your life
someone who has been bitten by a goose
while feeding bread to the doctor really
nailed that point home with me I'm go
damn right
all right 3 1 Dan moving to game point
right here there's so many lockdown the
geese where I would have to want to work
and they would surround me oh no I
almost got eaten by geese guys my gosh
you know what oh sit at home with my
several dogs in my millions of dollars
I'm gonna sit alone with that dog Daren
pew Don Ameche I'll take a gear with
shadow over ten years with your stupid
goose by a great great first question
all right this is game point lawn you
need this to keep her going chair do
Robert Pattinson we're just talking
about this guy he's our new Batman but
he's still getting a lot of grief for
starring in Twilight what Jack tower
actress deserves to be taken more
seriously which actor actress deserves
to be taken more seriously Adam Sandler
The Sandman man those things for the
mind just goes sure five four
I'll go go with Pattinson Twilight
co-star I'll go with Kristen Stewart in
case do we got the Sandman in case do I
call these two exclusively by their
nicknames we heard lon first said there
makes a lot of crummy movies fast
because he likes to go on vacation but
when you find him in a really good role
he can stick his team to do he's
actually great punch-drunk love even
among Paul Thomas Anderson's films is a
really accomplished film with a really
strong most actors even in good movies
will never reach that point in their
entire career and it's a shame that this
guy who's very talented at comedy
good at characters doesn't get more
respect at Kristen Stewart after
Twilight and after snow white and all
that stuff has consistently sought out
interesting work and yet continues to be
painted with the Twilight brush you
mentioned punch-drunk love that was what
2003 2004 Adam Sandler could have
written his own ticket but in any kind
of movies that he wanted he chose to
make crappy comedy after crappy comedy
after crappy comedy that's his choice he
made one interesting choice 15 years ago
I mean I think Paul who promised doesn't
get off of those kinds of roles because
he's been pigeon holding this thing
Kristen Stewart is in a lot of great
movies and people who love film already
know
Crysta towards Ben is my personal
Stoppard movies that wig festivals I
don't really underrated I think that she
is in the eyes of the general public
she's thought of as Bella she's thought
of as Twilight item summer wasn't pigeon
holed by someone else
he writes those movies and produces them
himself he makes those movies he's the
reason whoo all right mr. Kenneth sock
what do you think for films of people in
the comments saying I'm on my phone this
is called a timer track of the 20
seconds and I use it every week phone
calls these places so look Idol
punch-drunk loves one of my favorite
movies from that era I love Sandler but
dad kept hitting home the truth and long
kind of admitted it Sandler likes taking
his buddies on vacation and we'll bring
some cameras he doesn't care why should
we Kristen Stewart I think she liked
Pattinson will eventually get past that
Twilight label that a lot of the general
public puts on her I'm going dan Morrow
Billy biz
yeah look I I hate to make this
anti-climatic but that was to me
no brainer I think Dan really took that
one from the get-go and didn't let go so
I'm going down bow dan you took that you
took the game well played
dan moreau degrees from taylor lautner
just now we'll be taken seriously no
I've seen him act their co-star club
well Dan we've begun this this gauntlet
of matches and you made short work the
competition is that how this is gonna go
down are you calling your shot going
sweep all month long
never never this was humble as always
you know what I mean performed admirably
thanks everyone did I thought I loved
Danielle's arguments by winning him Dan
well played today this is fun
yes I I got heated I would never abandon
shadow
well if I lose this fire to a home
cynically we should all be so lucky to
have a good boy like shadow in our lives
yes yes so I just want to make sure the
guys at home knows that I would take
very good care of shadow yes yes the dog
to play shadow long deceased remember
that time you told me the Queen's corgis
oh yeah oh oh yeah I just delivered bad
news in a row upbeat way oh you and the
[ __ ] are cartoons that still several
more of those carnies have died by now
well played well who's gonna take the
box office this weekend by the way a
good question that's it's look at me the
reviews on Dark Phoenix aren't great
this year Life of pets - is animations a
big summer movie big strong play so a
lot of people are saying that the pets
may cylon the pets may rule the
box-office like not the one who's in
favor of not losing your faith their
cars
[Music]
so strong from the side of the table
looks like the Pens will take the box
office this weekend but you never know
comic book movies are very big this this
year you never know but it looks like
secret life of pets too might might take
the weekend right on Dan thank you sir
well fought all day Danielle I mean
super delightful and a lot of great
points love your Brian Tyree Henry uh
argument among others up please
yeah go ahead and shout out some stuff
oh yeah you know just do things that you
guys always do which you've already done
which you've already followed me on
Twitter thank you you've already
followed me on Instagram thank you I
will try to put up more posts again
trying to buy more dresses I do if you
like if you like wrestling I've got my
wrestling podcast tights and fights
which I believe is an interview does
that make you a real contender is a guy
which is gonna is it your stay
hey you know I have not seen wrestle
Twitter this excited about something new
in a really long time and I'm not gonna
get into this because I could literally
talk about it for an hour I do every
week on tights and fights right on but
this is one of those things where even
if aw is a huge competition only makes
everyone else better yeah you only make
it's never a bad thing to make Debbie W
have to rest yeah just step your game up
a little bit right on Danielle a thank
you so much mom great stuff all the way
long you probably need like smog or
something that guard the goose with the
cover than a sure
it's got a real attitude talking dragon
immune trust me that goose guards itself
perfectly calm in the movie
please help control the pet population
have your pet Spaniard thank you Bob
Barker can nap suck a rare treat to have
you sitting over there holding it down
thank you so much for coming in and
recreating this gruesome twosome from TV
fights can tell tell us please tell us
about your awesome book oh yeah and
where we can find you thanks for having
me everyone here Billy biz max Ryan JT
the whole team you know I've been a part
of a crate movie fights for a long time
and I know things start to change but
it's great to be back home and and we
can always have our memories except for
the ones that made with Billy yeah you
can go to Ken AFRICOM get information
word about my book why we love Star Wars
the great moments that built the galaxy
far far away and all the shows I do
cluding cast early talk with that men
over there long hairs where we talk
about gaming problems again thank you
kidnap stop mm-hmm lovely stuff Billy
biz yo this was a fun one I really had
fun I'm looking forward to the rest of
the month download download Danielle's
podcast buy this guy's book download the
cast early talk podcast watch dan on the
slowdown and then check out power levels
after you do all that on the screen
junkies yeah oh yeah
thanks really yeah I want to thank Billy
I want to thank JT e can everybody who
fought today and please follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at Hal Rudnick
lots of stupid stuff thoughts on movies
TV dumb characters yeah just get in
there mix it up hoot hoot everybody
thanks for watching see you next week
bye bye
you